how did we get here what happened what
happened to Star Wars what happened
where are we what weird alternate
dimension am I in it is said that time
fades even legend and so it was with the
optimism of Star Wars fans everywhere
including one former doe-eyed Curtain
cape-wearing fanboy twosome in our
universe the mess that was Star Wars
Episode nine the rise of Skywalker was
the death rattle of Star Wars movie
fandom but what if that wasn't the case
today we use our remote control of
imagination not to visit a reality where
they love the movies we hate or hate the
movies we love but rather to visit a
reality very much like our own safe for
one very important detail the movie
known as Star Wars Episode nine on this
may the fourth known to many as Star
Wars day I send you down this alternate
turn on the fork of the road of Star
Wars destiny to watch a review for Colin
Trevorrow conclusion of the Star Wars
sequel trilogy Star Wars Episode nine
duel of the fates as you watch you may
ponder which Episode nine you like more
theirs or ours but as you do remember
this one very important fact the force
will be with you always
[Music]
star wars episode 9 duel of the fates so
star wars episode 9 duel of the fates is
the final chapter in the Star Wars
trilogy and the Star Wars saga in
general is the numbered one so now
saying there's not gonna be more Star
Wars movies coming after this I'm saying
in terms of episodes 1 through 9 this is
that finale so hopefully in the world of
ups and downs of the Disney Star Wars
trilogy Colin Trevorrow can stick the
landing and I appreciate the fact that
from when this movie starts out the
opening crawl it establishes the reach
of the first-order because it boys
wonder that I'm like the first-order
they've just a group of terrorists are
they the government how big are they
duel of the fates establishes that the
reach of the first-order goes across the
galaxy they are essentially the
government there's even a public
execution and one scene in this movie
which I was really impressed so more
than a couple of occasions I feel like
duel of the fates has has more grit than
the previous two movies it takes more
chances it has more guts I'll get into
all of it so the plot is the resistance
has to go to Khorasan to the old jedi
temple and light this beacon that's
gonna call a bunch of ships to war
essentially cuz you know they need more
ships they need allies like I said the
first order is pretty huge not gonna lie
to you that beacon would have been
pretty helpful when separatist some
decades prior came to Coruscant to
kidnap the Chancellor they had a button
that would call people to their aid that
why didn't they use that don't know but
there's that and of course Rey and kylo
ren's or they're going to meet in their
duel of the face another thing I liked
about this movie is that it establishes
there's a bit of a time jump it's been
years since we last saw them in Star
Wars Episode 8 not just the fact that
rage she has Bobby she's powerful and at
first I was like of course she is but
she's been training under her master
Force ghost Luke I feel like if you're
gonna train under force ghost Luke that
would make you a badass so at least
there's a reason behind it this time not
only has Rey become more powerful kylo
Ren is no longer kylo Ren the outraged
emo boy no now he's kylo Ren the
questing man beard men that's right kylo
Ren straight up as some man Bush which
that scene where he goes to Mustafar to
Vader's old palace and he opens up
Vader's answering machine we'll call
that holocron it zaps his eyes and he
looks all [ __ ] up it's just like it
goes back to the dark side that's the
bad stuff and you're gonna look messed
up you look just one of the things I
like most about this movie is kylo Ren I
was actually I liked
his quest he's on a quest for power
which is yeah Darkseid quest for power
we get it but he doesn't seem to have
much regard for the first order
I feel like Vader was always like oh
we're gonna rule the galaxy in this
Empire I mean not saying kylo ren's
better than Vader Vader is always gonna
be king badass of Star Wars forever and
always to him in Palpatine
but kylo Ren at least has a concert he's
like Sephiroth oh he's like I don't care
about Shinra I just want to be powerful
it doesn't take a government to do that
just let me be some sort of God here I
lose on that kind of question here and I
dug it and even Hux I like the fact that
he was a little more confident I mean
he's still a little weasel but he's like
alright let's just let ray and kylo Ren
kill each other off in the name of their
archaic religion and I'll just rule
everything like the cockroach unscored
by the fallout I will be king of the
cinder it's it was within character with
him and at least he's looking towards an
end game he's still a joke in this movie
you know he's tries to use the Force a
couple times when he clearly can't a
couple people laugh at him like roses
whitey
haha so we're still a joke in scenes but
that's not all he is it's not his
defining character in here it's like
alright let's just smack the redhead
around because comedy I'm alright and
this movie does answer the important
questions like kind of force goes Jedi
come to a dark side user I guess force
ghost Luke not only trains Rey but also
haunts kylo Ren at least for one scene
he comes to kylo Ren talks to him kylo
hates it and strikes his lightsaber so
is that just a one-time thing I mean for
all we know when kylo Ren is laying in
bed trying to go to sleep force ghost
Luke could just be there singing I am
Henry the Eighth I am just sway seeing
the [ __ ] out of it's what I would do
absolutely so I don't know but now I
gotta be like well could obi-wan come to
Vader did he ever do that why did you
not do that so there are a couple things
in here that are neat to see but now I
have questions when it comes to the
original trilogy which I feel like has
happened a lot in this new trilogy now
in terms of Rey's character in this
movie they go out of their way to be
like you're not beholden to the old Jedi
rules there's some romance blooming
between her and Poe which kind of comes
out of nowhere and Leia's like look if
you you want to [ __ ] in the back of the
ship you totally can who's gonna stop
you the Jedi Council which I like the
fact that that is in there but I feel
like
Luke was in that situation too not that
Luke had a real love interest in the
original trilogy but afterwards he
totally was fine with getting down with
Mara Jade which I know isn't canon
anymore but let's be real it [ __ ]
should be
but I like the fact that it's like who
wrote that mean that whole rule wasn't
even established until episode 2 I
didn't know Jedi couldn't have love
interests which is a huge theme in this
movie which is like oh the Jedi didn't
have it figured out and balance comes
from within
someone embracing light and dark because
we all have that which is where this
trilogy was going so it does stay the
course on that which shows that Episode
nine wasn't as reactionary as that could
have been I at least appreciated that
about it speaking of things that they
could have been reactionary about that
they weren't Finn and Rose are on an
adventure again which they who are in
episode 8 and it was a really lame
adventure so when this what I mean they
go to press this button for a beacon
that's gonna go all right call every all
the ships and all the systems which they
do and then it gets shut down so I'm
like you're on another quest that really
led to nothing man they just cannot
catch a break however their quest is
still better than Kanto bite because
when you see Finn take a bunch of
stormtrooper defectors that he gave a
speech to one of them he's like you know
what you're right I am gonna defect with
you fn-2187
and there's scaling this big Walker like
they're a bunch of pirates scaling a
ship at sea let you look at that you're
like alright well this is how you make
up for Kanto by it it's true it's just
true it just is a hundred times better
there's actually a sweet battle he's
involved with and they at least seem to
realize alright well the writing for
Rose in the last movie sucked it doesn't
mean Rose the character and Nate Lee
sucks so let's throw her out there in a
mission with Finnegan because I feel
like that's a dynamic that could work if
there's just a better script to work
with also the fact that we're going back
to Coruscant in the first place that was
a neat bookend for me I mean when you
see the old Jedi Temple from the
prequels it's this neat book end of
prequel and sequel and you know when you
see it it really comes together for you
it's an element in the Star Wars sequels
that makes them feel less detached from
the rest of the saga again cool to see
raises questions why didn't Palpatine
burn that place down during his rule I
don't know but here we are
so now
kylo Ren is out there training with
Darth Plagueis as master he's teaching
him to Shang soom soul steel force
energy all this training leads to this
force vision fight kind of like Luke had
in the cave on Dagobah
yeah kylo Ren fights Darth Vader only
this time this fight is [ __ ] business
yeah this is Darth Vader you know like
the Darth Vader who slaughtered all
those rebels in the hallway it's not
just big clunky Darth Vader Darth
Vader's fighting prowess has evolved
over the years we saw that in Jedi
fallen order where it's just like he's
this unstoppable force and you see that
in this movie man this fight though it's
a Force fight it's not real it's pretty
awesome but still seeing Vader kick kylo
ren's ass you know that's Colin
Trevorrow like we know who the baddest
of the galaxy is be honest again
throwing back two Jedi fallen order
that's what raised light saber reminded
me of it's a double-sided light saber
that breaks apart now she has two single
bladed lightsabers also made for great
battle mechanics in the fighting in this
movie that's the thing that this movie
has this movie has great fights whether
it be Rey fighting the Knights of Ren
finally do something in this movie I
wish we would have gotten more setup
with them in Episode eight but
regardless I was actually glad to see
them on the hunt in this movie they do
feel menacing when you have one blocking
laser bolts with a lightsaber and then
shooting a gun with the other hand holy
[ __ ] the Knights of Ren why didn't we
see more than before one of them has the
dark saber which is how to get the dark
saber I don't know homies like that I'm
always like what series or book are you
gonna make to tie that in is that just
for selling that watch dark sabers in
the Mandalorian or something they won't
do that have you sweep them whether it
be that the end fight the space fights
the ground skirmishes with Finn in the
end fight all these star destroyers keep
coming into battle Leia just kind of
resigns the whole thing like I think
we've lost time to retreat before Lando
then comes in and saves the day all of
it really felt like Colin Trevorrow was
like dude this is the final chapter of
the final chapter we need it to feel big
we need it to feel spectacular he does a
pretty good job at having this movie
evoked that and cherry on top Lando
doesn't die that's good I swore he was
in episode 9 he was gonna die I first
would race she's fighting one of the
Knights of Ren and she just cooks him
with Force Lightning and at first I was
like but you're not gonna turn bad but
by the end of the movie
it's not going good versus bad it's good
and bad and you have both because we all
have both which I feel like does take an
element of the mysticism out of it you
know it's of course that's how people
are that's how people are Jedi weren't
like that that's what made Jedi Jedi
they were so good but obviously they're
lost without the dark side on this side
light side on this side does it feel
like fundamentally does it feel like
Star Wars anymore but while I'm
marinating on that we'll talk about the
fact that I raise parents we get raised
parentage in here were they nobodies yes
a lot of fans were like dude well kylo
Ren said they were junk traders they're
not gonna be that and I guess they're
not no kylo Ren killed her parents and
they took her to jakku to save her to
save her life we shouldn't you find out
Ben solo turned and became kylo Ren when
he was 17 raised about three in that
flashback where she's like combat which
is a 14-year age difference how old is
kylo Ren regardless that means Luke's
students were killed sixteen years
before the force awakens which means
Luke has been missing for 16 years the
whole time [ __ ] means and the less Jedi
when he's like I came to this island to
dies like you've been here for 16 years
on this island with a bunch of high
cliffs sixteen years you haven't found a
way to do well watch it watch your step
that fall kill you yeah let's find a way
to die here for 16 year Wow I mean did
you bring your green lightsaber with you
you can go ahead and pale yourself with
that like Hux does in this movie when
the battles lost which is one thing
where I'm like I kind of called [ __ ]
on that but Hux have the balls to impale
himself with a lightsaber I don't know
we'll be there be like it's but hey it's
a purple lightsaber impales himself with
Mace Windu's lightsaber I'll take a mace
windu Easter egg wherever I can
regardless let's appreciate the fact
that Harrison Ford came back one last
time for that flashback scene and if he
into the movie when it leads to the Ray
kylo Ren showdown epic as John Williams
even has duel of the fates playing in
their namesake of the movie again book
ending it just making it feel a bit more
real like episode 1 music in episode 9
but then an unexpected turn where Ray's
kind of let's face it she's been iddqd
the entire time God mode she actually
kylo Ren slashes and nails or eyes and
blinds her which I know a lot of people
are gonna be like
from rebels that's that's a total your
gonna think of Kanan I don't know why I
think a neo from the matrix revolutions
I just do concluding chapter of a
trilogy and then you know hero gets
blinded I just thought of its a neo
thing for me but that's important I like
the fact that she actually took physical
damage that hurt her I mean kylo Ren has
now learned how to kill people via Shang
zooming them just soul stealing which he
does to Plagueis his master I kind of
call [ __ ] on that I'm like Plagueis
is master you learned this thing from
him and then you just kill him with it I
feel like he'd be like what do you do
what do you know [ __ ] you get away kid
even if you have a beard you're Punk to
me but okay he kills him but they could
have just had him do that to her and be
like oh hey there you go that's how he
beats her somewhere in this saga Rey
needed to take a physical hit that
really just kind of [ __ ] her up a hit
that just makes us feel like oh wow
Anakin got his arm sliced off well in
Episode three he took a lot more damage
Luke got his hand sliced off Rainey did
something like this if kylo Ren just
like souls after that wouldn't have been
enough that would have been a little
anticlimactic I feel like I would have
walked out of the movie theater being
like I feel like she didn't take any
damage it would have felt like the 90
spiderman cartoon when they had Michael
Morbius the living vampire but you can't
have a vampire bite next and drink blood
so we're gonna have little suction cups
on his palms and he's gonna grab people
by the face and he's going to drain
their plasma that's what it would have
felt like for me if the only damage Rey
took was some sort of soul steel that
kylo Ren might have done to her that he
does do in this movie after he slashes
her eyes and blinds and then kylo Ren
turns good it was I felt like that was
kind of abrupt I get that layout called
out to him and it's like he's evil kylo
Ren for this movie and then he's like uh
okay I guess I'm good and they kind of
touched foreheads he tells her her name
Rey Solana he's like your name's ray
Solana Solana is your last time goodbye
wait just what I was sweating at that
point I was like if they kiss don't go
this is gotta be the most awkward oh
they didn't and then Ray's in force
ghost heaven with Yoda Luke and obi-wan
they're all pretty much like you can
stay here or you can go back and
logical person in that situation would
probably be like in the words of James
Tiberius Kirk I've done my bit for king
and country yeah I need to do it I let
me just hang out here but she doesn't
she goes back which I liked the movie a
lot more when it looked like you didn't
know you know the movie kind of leaves
off if like did she or didn't she we
don't know people are gonna go looking
for her Finn and Rose are gonna help
force users and give them a little safe
haven there's actually really digging
this weird ambiguous ending where maybe
we wouldn't know if Rey came back or not
and then it shows old she does and I was
like okay I guess you want a bow on it
you just put a bow right on top okay
sweet done she's fine and she can see
again which kind of makes the whole
damage thing okay negates that but in
the end Star Wars duel of the fates I
ended up having a good time with it
there are some things in here that I'm
like to do that just for fanservice I
don't know is anyone asking for Chewie
to fly an x-wing fighter do we once
again need the first order to have the
ability to blow up planets no however in
terms of nostalgia bate my favorite part
other than you know the plot of Khorasan
and the Jedi Temple have already said I
like that I'm talking to stal jebaited
if something that was just thrown on
screen for the sick of haha here you got
a memory lane [ __ ] the scene where r2d2
is playing back everything from his
perspective and it's just kind of
chronicles the Star Wars saga because
he's been there for a little bit that
was a nice little way to close the book
on all of it it's a it's a trip down
memory lane I enjoyed that it's been a
rocky ride there's been some ups and
downs in terms of the Disney Star Wars
trilogy of episodes 7 8 and 9 episode 7
gave us a lot of promise it hyped a lot
of people up I was jacked I feel like
the sequel trilogy starting with episode
7 which just is like that politician who
made all those promises and then just
didn't follow through with any of it
sweet yeah yeah I promise you'll get it
all these promises on the campaign trail
four years later it's like where's any
of that
yeah well terms over now by but in the
end I feel like Colin Trevorrow
delivered a Star Wars adventure that
felt like a Star Wars adventure the best
of his ability anyway having to
springboard off of some of the previous
decisions made in previous episodes that
we might consider missteps it's not
perfect no I look at episode 9 and I'm
like here's what would have made it all
better is if you got JJ Abrams Ryan
Johnson and Colin Trevorrow in a room
together for pre-production of the new
trilogy before pre-production of Episode
seven even started just lock them in a
room together for like a month and be
like you all hammer out the plot get on
the same page so there are no
contradictions we just we know where
we're all going they didn't do that so
Colin Trevorrow gave us what I feel is
the best he could have done in terms of
episode seven the force awakens episode
eight the last Jedi in Episode nine duel
of the fates
I feel like duel of the fates is the
best original Star Wars adventure we've
gotten of the three it's really nice to
force awakens' because I was jacked up
and fanboying and yeah promise it's
looking back that I feel like this is
the best of the three in terms of
original adventure I'll say duel of the
fates it's worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray
we'll see where Star Wars goes after
this but for nothing else Colin
Trevorrow has my respect for not
pandering and not doing damage control
due to backlash for episode a he could
have had some easy calls being like well
we'll just do this that'll be easy ray
needs a last name will make her
Palpatine or Skywalker's or something
I'll be easy Oh ray Lowe's they really
want them to kiss alright well we'll
have them kiss when kylo kind of turns
not so evil at the end abrupt yes but
that'll be easy
kylo needs to train with a super bad
baddie a let's make it some Palpatine
clone or something there we go that'll
be easy he didn't do that that maybe I'm
over each Inge I don't think anyone
would have done that alright so Star
Wars Episode nine duel of the fates have
you seen it what you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]